electric vehicles have become more
popular and more accessible
one of the guiding principles of the
belief that electric vehicles will take
over from internal combustion is the
falling cost of batteries from a pack
price of around twelve hundred dollars
per kilowatt hour in 2010 the prices
have dropped to 137 dollars per kilowatt
hour by 2020.
there was an expectation of costs below
100 by 2023 by which point evs would hit
a comparable price to equivalent
internal combustion vehicles and the
game would be over for oil and gas
but the global surge in lithium prices
have led some to question whether this
stream would really become a reality
lithium carbonate prices have been
dropping since a peak in 2018 of around
15 000 per ton to half that price by the
end of 2020 according to edison group
but in large part due to the demand for
evs the price has been growing all
through 2021 hitting over 25 000 per ton
by the end of last year and now reaching
over 40 thousand dollars per ton
ev demand is only going up some experts
say that production can't scale because
lithium prices will hold it back along
with surging prices of other minerals
cobalt has gone from thirty thousand
dollars per ton in 2020 to eighty
thousand dollars per ton today and
nickel has surged even more from twenty
thousand dollars per ton to eighty
thousand dollars per ton according to
trading economics
the doubling tripling and quadrupling of
key elements in lithium-ion batteries
sounds almost lethal for the price
reductions and volume growth in the last
couple of years
however there are a few other factors to
take into consideration
first while these elements are expensive
just how much of each one actually goes
into an ev battery and the overall
vehicle price
just over half of the price of a typical
ev battery cell comes from the minerals
in the cathode with 12 percent from the
graphite in the anode
the popular nmc cathode type uses
lithium nickel manganese and cobalt the
latter three giving the nmc name for the
anode
a typical high nickel nmc design such as
lg's is 811 referring to how it has 80
nickel 10 manganese and 10 cobalt
while the costs of nickel and cobalt
have exploded alongside lithium
manganese hasn't increased in price to
the same level but most of the minerals
that make up about half of a lithium-ion
battery sell price have gone up by
orders of magnitude and cost which could
in theory mean as much as a tripling of
the price per kilowatt hours of ev
batteries although there have been some
ev cost increases for example tesla
increased its uk model 3 pricing there
hasn't been significant inflation from
other manufacturers other than the four
court gouging due to the universal chip
shortage
if the 2021 pack price was 132 dollars
per kilowatt hour even the 100
kilowatt-hour monster batteries in the
most high-end luxury vehicles should
only have cost around 13 000
but in reality there is a huge markup
that can soften the blow to the end
customer
as michael libreck of bloomberg nef and
liebrick associates pointed out in a
tweet we've been here before with
silicon a huge surge in silicon prices
in 2008 led some to argue that solar
panels would not scale but a year later
prices were back down again and then
continued to fall
solar panels are now less than a third
of the price they were per watt in 2010
the high ev battery mineral prices are
also likely to be a blip
there's nothing like a high mineral
price to encourage more production as
mining companies look to cash in
lithium is being described as quote
white gold and there are numerous
startups looking to exploit reserves
because it's actually fairly abundant
technological development in battery
chemistry will also play a factor
if some minerals are too expensive
battery chemistry can be changed
nmc anodes aren't the only choice there
is also lithium titanate lithium cobalt
oxide and lithium manganese oxide
tesla has switched to using lithium iron
phosphate or lfp catl batteries for the
basic model 3 currently on sale in
europe
the surge in the price of lithium and
other current minerals used in ev
batteries is a concern but we've been
here before
just as the switch to evs is part of the
solution to the problem of co2 emissions
and climate change technological
innovation will find a way forward for
ev batteries as it always has in other
areas
the smooth curve in battery pricing
towards electric and internal combustion
vehicle price parity may have hit a
speed bump but the general direction of
travel remains the same